ومن جانبه قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي قال ان المحادثات
الاخيره التي جرت امس في باريس وضمت
الولايات المتحده وقطر ومصر واسرائيل كانت
بناء واضاف كيري في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه ان هناك كثيرا من العمل الذي
يجب القيام به للتوصل الى صفقه جديده
لاطلاق سراح الاسرى
كانت المحادثات بناءه لكن اريد ان اكون
حذرا وان لا اكون متفائلا جدا هناك الكثير
من العمل يجب القيام به للتوصل الى صفقه
رهائن اخرى مما سيسمح ليس فقط باخراج
الرهائن بل ايضا بدخول المساعدات والحد من
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين وكانت مناقشات
جديه الغايه مع القطريين والمصريين
والاسرائيليين لكننا لم نصل الى خط
النهايه بعد ولا استطيع ابلاغكم في الوقت
الحالي انه سيتم الاعلان عن اتفاق قريب
جدا لكن نشعر بالرضى تجاه المفاوضات والى
اين
تتجه